katia bonsoir nouveau confinement donc
annoncé ce soir qu'est ce qu'il faut
retenir de la prise de parole du chef de
l'état oui exactement la situation
sanitaire se dégradent trop emmanuel
macron l'a dit les mesures prises ne
suffisent plus alors leur confinement va
redémarrer à partir de vendredi et ce
durant un mois mais il sera différent
affirmé le chef de l'état puisque les
français continueront à travailler
l'économie doit être protégée at il
insisté alors le télétravail va être
généralisé mais certains secteurs et
bien continueront à fonctionner un comme
avant plus ou moins dix ans le btp par
exemple secteur agricole est également
les services publics et l'administration
parlant des écoles elles resteront
ouvertes c'était une grande
interrogation elles resteront verte en
souvenir de la crèche jusqu'au lycée
seules les universités seront fermés en
revanche concernant les commerces et
établissements accueillant du public et
bien tous seront fermés c'est à dire que
seuls les commerces de première
nécessité resteront ouverts ce qui
signifie fermeture des bars des restos
des salles de sport et là des mesures de
soutien économiques seront mises en
place avec le retour du chômage partiel
des mesures de trésorerie est des
mesures de soutien économique tous
azimuts pour aider c'est un secteur
fragilisé et concernant les
autorisations de sortie vous propose
d'écouter emmanuel macron quant au
printemps vous pourrez sortir de chez
vous uniquement pour travailler vous
rendre à un rendez vous médical pour
porter assistance à un proche pour faire
vos courses essentielles ou prendre
l'air à proximité de votre domicile
c'est donc le retour de l'attestation
comme au printemps les réunions privées
en dehors du strict noyau familial
seront donc exclus les rassemblements
publics seront interdits et vous ne
pourrez pas vous déplacer d'une région à
l'autre à l'exception des retours de
vacances de la toussaint les commerces
qui ont été définies au printemps comme
non essentiels les établissements
recevant du public notamment les bars et
restaurants seront fermées comme au
printemps le quoi qu'il en coûte cette
réponse économique
parmi les plus protectrices du monde se
poursuivra elle sera même plus important
ce qu'en plus importante qu'en mars pour
une petite entreprise fermée
administrativement
avec la prise en charge jusqu'à 10000
euros par mois de leurs pertes en
chiffre d'affaires les salariés et les
employeurs qui ne peuvent pas travailler
continueront quant à eux à bénéficier du
chômage partiel et nous compléterons par
des mesures de trésorerie pour les
charges
les loyers des prochaines semaines et un
plan spécial sera fait pour les
indépendants les commerçants les très
petites et moyennes entreprises qui je
le sais redoutent plus que tout les
prochaines semaines l'art contrairement
aux premiers confinement les visites
dans les ehpad seront autorisées et les
mesures de contrôles sanitaires aux
frontières seront renforcés avec des
tests systématiques
voilà ce qu'il faut retenir de la
locution à des manuels macron sachant
que toutes ces mesures seront détaillées
avec précision demain par le
gouvernement merci beaucoup
katia pour toutes ces précisions katia
technique en direct depuis l'elysée